all right
zanthoria let's do it
team black again
do i want to play the sicilian if e4 is
there no e4
okay maybe a king's indian
another five ten
is on thoria feels like it has been a
while since we played a game
okay let's go
g6
no grunfeld
um gonna try to okay so white is not
going with the
the most popular
e4
so
what does this mean it's white is giving
me another opportunity to
play d5
and something i like about playing d5
here is that if we have this capture i
get to recapture with the knight
and not only is the bishop
contributing but i like this tempo
against the bishop on f4
so
i think if i play this one
white won't initiate the capture
but instead
play e3
and be in a spot to meet that with that
so let me see
d5 e3 d5 e3
i don't want to do this
um
what about c5 in that position
c5 takes
queen a5
is that a move
i think i need to play with c5
to
extend the scope of this dark square
bishop
eventually i need to play c5 so i think
i'm going to first start with this one
i'll go with d5 i'm not sure how this is
going to play out
okay e3 it is
all right let's go it's c5
things are heating up
see how it reacts to this pressure
chop here chop there
if this i'm gonna
no no no if this one um um i'm cool with
recapturing with my knight
yeah and if that one i think this is
where i now play that the queen a5
yeah let's go queen a5
am i asking for some trouble if i do
[Music]
that i supposed to play something else
so be careful here queen a5 queen a4
might be a move
queen takes c5
pawn takes knight takes
that should be all right there
all right let's begin with this one
so i have this as an idea
so if a second pawn is knocked out
94.
i don't know
so this one knight e4
bishop e5
bishop takes knight takes knight takes
knight
there's queen d2
i'm in a pin so this is a an important
resource to be familiar with in some
variations
if
this guy captures this one you don't
necessarily have to recapture right away
you have a tactic based on an
unprotected piece
namely the queen on a5
queen d2
an important note in position types like
this
okay in the end
queen b3
queen b3
okay
what's the plan i have to be precise
here
hmm
oh i play this right now though
yeah 94 i think
all right yeah let's let's get this one
in here
let's see
so i have pressure on a couple points
the main one is c3 now
hit three currently defended twice
but also
this one
hitting the queen getting the pawn back
i'm castled my opponent is still two out
from castling so i would like to try and
stir up trouble
okay rook there so i could begin with
knight takes night
and
give white tripled pawns though
they'll undouble
on triple
the one triple
i should be getting this guy
with maybe the queen
right now i'm not so sure about that
what am i considering this one
is this such a good choice i don't think
so
take the knight
hmm
what's wrong with this and then maybe i
could return
knight takes c5
they take c5 queen b5
this bishop takes knight a mode that's a
dangerous one
i wonder though
i'm doing a really good job of
crushing my time
i'm gonna keep my uh
keep my dark square bishop
i think maybe take here now
try to get this guy back
knight a6 knight d7
still two miles and moves out from
castling bishop takes
queen takes c5
pawns are split
okay queen takes it is
queen here queen there
let me start with this one knight a6
if i could win this pawn back
conveniently
i should be better
i'd be the better developed side
and i have the healthier structure
so
that's all i'm looking forward to right
here
i i want to get this pawn back
and things should
be good for me but
maybe white could interfere with that
let's see how white tries to
cling to this pawn
what tries are there
still two moves out from castling so
if white is
opting for variations that welcome more
exchanges
that's uh
going to allow these guys to maybe
contribute
the tactics may
may be tipping in my favor
if the position is opening up more
since i have the more active pieces
what to do
queen exchange
chop right here
this pond's unprotected
okay i thought this should maybe be a
move i didn't want to voice it in case
my opponent was listening
i'm going to take with
the knight
because
i think i think it's fine to take with
the queen but i want to squeeze a little
bit more out of this
um
queen post
i think
you know i i have a healthy pick here
with bishop to e6 or maybe b6 bishop a6
and right now this pawn is
is what i'm is what i'm going to be
after next um
now that i've regained the material i'm
looking forward to putting pressure on
the weak links c3
so i was pointing out these moves i have
to have to be fast here bishop e6
i think bishop e6 is
most
no
yeah we'll go bishop e6
i could do without b6
i think
queen there
oh
i didn't see that move
man
so much for
isolated pawn
i did not want to bring these guys
together
maybe i could still have something
though with the knight on knight on c3 i
have bishops functioning on adjacent
diagonals so
maybe that counts for something
i yeah i didn't see that move
queen b4 is nice
i think i should have done something
else
maybe taking on c5 directly with the
queen was better come to think of it
his pawn's under fire
how irritating will a knight be on this
square
i think we're
close to finding out
i'm leaning more towards rook f2 d8 than
this one i want to keep open the option
to open up the a file with a5
that move
did not consider that
the old double attacker
let's begin with this
see how
white reacts to knight takes bishop
it does hit with check
maybe this is the piece that wants to
track down this pawn it's a
pac-man mode
okay about
a little bit a little bit here
keep some pressure
i really don't want to have to go into a
prevent
and start to babysit one of these two
i'm
still looking for some offensive moves
so
maybe now i
when i grab this pawn
yeah
maybe maybe this guy stays here because
now i'm ready to take here and be on the
bishop so
i think i'm
gonna be up upon
let's see though
um opponent needs a flight square oh
there's rook takes here defending the
pawn
okay
all right but the rook could be kicked
away
let's start with this
take here i take here
and then maybe i run with this guy
right
this rook might be short on squares
okay
bishop here move
now let me begin with this one
bishop here possibly
i know you know what i think i need to
get rid of this guy
let's start with this
if bishop here i'm gonna go here or
maybe this this is a possibility
yeah this move if the bishop exchanges
decline knight d5
okay rook is hit
now this guy is really well positioned
be careful though
this rook is really active
hmm
i don't know that i want to move with my
knight
let's go here
a little concerned about
moving my knight and then knight g5
putting pressure on this point
oh okay i think i'll take here
rather the bishop there then
than uh
a rook arriving there
how jumpy can my night be
i don't think
it's gonna get trapped
knight d5 knight d3
opponent still needs a flight square
and let's let's stay central
bishop there
think now's the time to run
let's not invite this
knight forward
and i want
white to converge on f7
now this guy has not moved but it is
it's ideally placed behind the past pawn
still need a flight square i want to get
these moves in
knight here pawn here and then a rook on
b1
that's the configuration the ideal
configuration
let's see how white tries to interfere
with that
we both continue to live off the
increment
keep pushing i guess
keep my knight right where it is still
flexible
white is on the defensive i could also
consider a long-winded approach but i
think
i think i should still keep pushing
push push again
how
how is
i don't think white is able to interfere
with this plan i have
push here
knight here push
here i can't go here but i could go
there
this king's a long ways away
oh i think it's
here
here
here here
here i'm not in time
[Music]
so i think i should start with that
tough tough tough
oh maybe i could uh i could be sneaky
if this
then maybe
i could reposition my rook
because there's the indirect defense i
think now's my time to pivot with the
rook and get to the seventh
yeah
rook b1
super timely
okay now rook b2
still defending the pawn
and hitting other stuff
and now
now i am
ready to play this move soon
not just yet
ah
irritating move where is it or is it no
i give the check first
i'll go with this one
panicked there
good luck to exchange nights now 1992
there's a better way
pretty sure there's a better way
i think the king is a little too far off
i i should be getting another pawn
being up one pond
i think is good enough but
certainly feel
much more comfortable if i could get
that second one
there's no h3
h4 may have been a try
so now let's
take up a strong king post
if king here then there's no there's no
approaching so now
i work with the majority
right away
the knight moves i get the pawn if
there's a king move it's
not progress
so it's in a
a tough spot i want to keep this guy
here
advance these as as far as like they can
as far as i could go
there may be a trick
oh no this is defended
just thinking for a second after this
this check this pond falls but i have
this covered
okay i think we still keep rolling
and go with this
if i can improve my king further
[Music]
or this with this one
here we go with this
i don't like that that's nice even has
checks let me take up a strong king post
and i don't want this to arrive
too well positioned and now i think next
up these two
this one
take with check and then i'm defending
the promotion square as well
um maybe i could take one tiny timeout
with f6
think this
will inconvenience white a hair
king really doesn't want to make a move
away from
the eventual passer
time time time okay barely
and now i could play this one he's a
little further away and i should be
pushing through now
no good checks
i got that one covered
okay very good games on thoria i'm sure
we missed a lot in the opening middle
game
okay let's have a look at it
let's request
an analysis
okay
it's still thinking
see this opening
d5
likes d5
like c5 look we're playing like uh
yvonne chuck and carlson from 2013.
six moves in
we're still playing like them
playing like kramnik and evanchuk
okay we're still we're still on a pretty
a pretty good path
okay this is where it's a little
different after queen b3 what is it
suggesting rook c1
is the
top move
lending support to this point
okay so after queen b3
is it done thinking
all right there's your
there's your eval
oh i guess there was some big misses
bishop e2 i had something 12 moves in
okay
rick c1 better
let's say 94
c takes d5
knight takes e3 pawn takes knight d7
okay sure
gonna be down a pawn i have a good night
okay just get some idea
sugar not thank you for the tier one sub
appreciate your support
let's exchange pawns that was you good
game man
good one
all right so
in the game queen b3
that's better
queen b3 not losing
um
okay apparently bishop e5 is is
necessary
to offset this pressure on the knight i
didn't take advantage of this i guess
i captured on c3 this is where i chewed
up two minutes
chop on c3 that's no good
wants to play knight d7
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i could afford to bring this i was too
concerned about getting my pawn back
as soon as possible okay this would have
been better
chop on c4
and now it's cons
it's winning for me
bishop e6
oh i took the pawn oh if i play bishop
e6 first
bishop e6 first this knight is
controlling the b4 square
ah
so when i take like this and then play
here queen b4 is excellent best
oh yeah she doesn't have any other
squares well she has b5
but
yeah look at the evaluation even
material i could get this pawn
it's it's pretty pretty bad
for white
in this situation
okay yeah that's that's an important
note there
i did not want to bring these guys
together
wrong wrong order
knight takes their queen before
chop chop
then how is it looking right around here
okay there still is some some winning
move i missed
rook fd8 is good
oh
i could play here and this stops both of
these moves because i have a night check
winning the bishop
so i could get rid of this
active rook
ah
okay i
kind of gave up and went pawn
hunting yeah and this is where it became
equal again
equal equal equal
yeah this is this is this is going to be
tough to defend now
tough to defend for white when is it
broken
uh yeah this this is this is a really
tall task
yeah it's a tall task
doesn't like the pawn move knight b4
yeah
i don't know
i wonder if the king needed to sneak
over on e1
staying out of the checks
i can't pivot here
now
so
maybe that one
it still says black's winning but
it made life a lot easier once i was
able to transfer the rook there
and now i went knight f4
this one here is not working yeah
this and then here
there's knight b3
that's what i realized at the last
second
down to just a few seconds when i played
knight f4 okay
knight f4
and it's it should be gonzo from here
yeah i wonder if it was a better
approach
cleaner approach now it says rook takes
or takes a2
okay
again good game
oh rook b1 instead of b2 i think that
isn't working
i think there's something fancy there
um
yeah
so this here
rook b1 i don't believe is working
oh it is working
rook b1
oh
you know what i missed i missed that
after this here i was thinking the king
could move and counter-attack my rook
but i have that covered
that's what i
missed okay rook b1 straight away
can be played and then after knight c2
there's a fancy move knight b4
what if knight b3
i could
take all right good game
you